so maybe by now um you're starting to
get a little suspicious right remember
natural log right it's actually
shorthand it's right here for log
base
e
right and e is this strange number
2.7182 something something something
okay has to do with exponential growth
okay
so therefore if i think about the
special case okay
um
where
oops
my constant a right
it's not just any number one two three
four five but if it was actually equal
to that base number e okay
so let a
equal e therefore the derivative of
e to the x
right well e is just a number okay and
i'm raising it to this power it would be
equal to e to the x multiplied by
log base e of e
okay now remember what logs mean why's
mean what power do i have to raise this
to this bottom number
or how do i have to raise it to get this
number the top number well the power i
need to raise it to is
one right so in fact the derivative of
the exponential function
is itself
okay you differentiate this thing and it
never changes okay
okay now that means that when you think
about what e to the x looks like okay
that means that at any particular point
its gradient is
its y value so for instance okay let's
think about um the y intercept there
okay at x equals zero what's the y
intercept
it's one right that means that the
gradient of
e to the x at that position is
one in fact this line is x plus one and
you can verify it's a tangent you can
i'll show you why in a second
okay all right so here's this important
result right now how do we bring this
together with all of the other rules
that we know like say chain rule okay
what would be the derivative of say e to
the i don't know 2x
now
you gotta be careful okay because you
look at this line you're like well i
differentiate this e to the whatever and
it's just
whatever it doesn't change okay
but be careful right
this from here to here is a function of
a function so this is this is chain rule
in here okay so what i'll do is again
with chain rule you're probably starting
to get familiar with it you don't always
put the substitution in let this equal u
equal this blah blah but i'm going to do
it to illustrate a point okay so
let's
have y equals e to the 2x
okay
and i'm going to introduce the
substitution so i can use chain rule on
this so i'm going to say let u
equal
e to the sorry no i just want 2 to the x
okay 2x
so therefore
y equals 2 sorry e to the power of u
straight substitution is that ok
so i've done my replacement now the next
part of chain rule is the inside of the
outside right so the derivative
d u and dx is equal to
2 right
and the derivative d y on d u because
that's what i replaced stuff with is now
this thing that doesn't change right
that's just e to the power of one of
them right so that's just e to the u
okay so now when you put your chain
together right d y on the x
is the y under u
times d u
on the x so that my d u's just cancel
out okay
i'm gonna get e to the u times two
which is two e to the two
okay
does that make sense so what you've got
here
the derivative on the 2x
this 2 came down out front because it's
the inside function
okay just like if you differentiated
sine 2x
okay if you did your exercises on this
right it's not just equal to cos 2x
right sine doesn't just turn into cosine
you've got an inside function so this is
really equal to
2 cos 2x
okay
all right
um
let me do one more example just for the
sake of it okay um
just to get your brains practicing
material
y equals e to the
x
squared
it looks terrible because you're like
how many indexes do this does this have
right it just goes on forever uh what do
i do with this well i differentiate the
inside
and then i'll differentiate the outside
okay so dy dx here is well the inside
function is x squared right so its
derivative is
just 2x bring the power down
reduce the power by one and now
differentiate the outside which is e to
the power of something and e to the
power of something doesn't change okay
so it'll be e to the x squared
okay